the question that I also thought it was
gonna was gonna pop up this afternoon is
does anybody here in any
sans think that the consciousness is an
illusion and what do they mean by that
an illusion well right so what do you
mean by that it's only losing the same
sense it's very well could you elaborate
on that because I there is no me in the
brain that's so for wearing what kind of
philosophical Tyra makes it that's why I
mean the the figure of that our
consciousness is simply an Epiphone and
I'll be a one that might been put there
by natural selection or a coalition of
neurons that we have that makes us feel
that there is an agent well it could be
okay I mean yeah well that's what I
wanted to actually figure out because no
I think that's this is important
distinction here if we if we agree that
it's a phenomenon so for instance let me
let me try to clarify what I was going
with this so I've heard not from people
in this room but did the argument that
oh well we know that conscience is an
illusion because if you look at split
brain patients they have you know sort
of multiple and conflicting sort of
desires and all that sort of stuff to me
that shows nothing of the sort it simply
shows that when the brain doesn't work
properly as natural selection intended
so to speak then you get interesting
phenomena you know that intense
phenomena of that sort but it's a non
functional brain it's a malfunctioning
brain so it doesn't let me finish it
dream you also don't know what's going
on sure
surprising other parts of you sure yeah
you have to go to non functional to say
okay but but what I'm saying what I'm
saying is that it seems to me especially
from a naturalistic purely naturalistic
perspective that we don't need to do
anything like denying consciousness in
any you know to say the consciousness is
an illusion any strong sense of the word
all we need to say is yeah of course it
comes out of parts underlying it just
like the functioning of a car comes out
of parts
the linemen and if you break the
steering wheel it's not gonna work
anymore it's gonna do something bizarre
right you didn't want to say that the
the car going straight is an illusion
because when you take the wheels apart
it doesn't happen anymore right
so yes it's made of parts it's an
emergent property in the weak sense in
in this case or an AP phenomenal in the
strong sense I don't know which way you
want to go I think a phenomenon it's
it's probably better so that's what I
wanted to know if they watching this
room I agree with that as opposed to
sort of what I sometimes finca Elvis
facile oh the split brain shows that
it's all an illusion therefore there is
no me well there is you in an
interesting sense of you biologically
evolutionarily in terms of decision
making and moral responsibility if you
want to come back to the earlier
discussion but of course that you comes
out of pieces that interact in certain
ways and the job of neurobiologist among
other things is to figure out how
exactly these pieces interact to yield
not too much but yeah so my and the
difference of me this this self that is
so important I mean um crucially I need
stuff besides what's in my brain for
that right I have to build a bowl bunch
of I have to hang a bunch of scaffolding
out in the environment right to keep
myself on track and to keep to be able
to sort of reaiiy denta fie myself and
remind myself of the constraints that
I'm trying to to respect and I also need
other people to give me feedback that
tells me that I'm staying on track and
so on and so on and so great so so that
we can involve when we're talking what
we're dealing with the self we invite
all sorts of pseudo problems and we also
invite lots of really naive eliminative
ISM from neuroscientists by thinking but
but by trying to get that whole self
inside the inside the skullcap
you